Selfies are beautiful.
Who hasn't been thrilled by the self photographer?
Those fabulous narc-artists who allow us to bask in the brightness of their shine.
But these egotastic specimens of visual self-obsession are in danger.
Danger caused by this.
They used to be focused on just themselves like how their hair was the bomb...
...or how adorbs their new shoes were.
Just hashtag, hashtag, hashtag.
Now they realized they can take pictures that capture so much more.
Given their propensity to compare, compete and outdo each other,...
...selfie sticks in the hands of these vain glorious Van Goghs are growing in size,...
...doubling and tripling in length.
Please warn those you love about the dangers of selfie stick abuse.
Please selfie responsibly.